[Music]
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning and it is a bad day for the
world's biggest social network as
whatsapp facebook and instagram all go
dark and their shares plunge we're live
at the company's california headquarters
to ask exactly what went wrong plus new
powers to curb climate protests as well
as a promise to do more to address
violence against women and girls we'll
be speaking to the policing minister kit
malthouse in just a few minutes time but
also this morning climate concerns i'm
going to be joined by the prime
minister's father stanley johnson to
talk about the government's green
strategy ahead of the cop 26 summit also
coming up
[Music]
well it's garage music but not quite as
you might know it from a carport in
surrey to the top of the american charts
i'll be speaking to the singer who
became an overnight sensation after
three decades of trying it is tuesday
the 5th of october
status updates facebook whatsapp
instagram all back online after a global
outage that paralyzed the world's
biggest social networks but what exactly
caused it
i'm live at facebook headquarters in
california as the tech giant does damage
control and says sorry after its biggest
ever crash
i'm live at the conservative party
conference in manchester for a big day
on law and order as the home secretary
promises to get tough on motorway
protesters
i'm live in beijing as china sends a
record number of aircraft into taiwan's
air defense zone ratcheting up regional
tensions and drawing condemnation from
the us
by nearly half the toys bought online
through third-party sellers could harm
kids
a life-saving drug for a rare blood
disorder the first sickle cell treatment
in 20 years is rolled out in england
the language of genocide now being used
in ethiopia's brutal civil war we'll
have a special report at half past nine
[Music]
morning all right we begin with a status
update the world's biggest social
network is back online after an outage
that lasted several hours
facebook whatsapp and instagram all
crashed last night with millions of
users unable to send or receive messages
or refresh their news feeds
well the outage had an impact on three
of the company's core products social
networks facebook and instagram as well
as the messaging service whatsapp
affecting an estimated three billion
combined users
the website monitoring service down
detector said it was the largest such
failure it had ever seen with 10.6
million problems reported globally
and with shares falling almost 5
yesterday the company lost 34.8
billion pounds in market value almost 50
billion dollars
facebook has now confirmed that a faulty
configuration change caused the outage
the company has also said
there is no evidence to suggest that
user data was compromised our us
correspondent mark stone has this
morning's first report
a wheel and a word on screens globally
and representing an outage with
implications which grew hour by hour it
was just before 9am yesterday at
facebook hq in california when staff
noticed a problem within minutes across
the globe facebook was down and with it
it's affiliate platforms instagram and
whatsapp an estimated three billion
users social networks business networks
all cut off
but after more than five hours which
showed just how dependent the world has
become on facebook
it was back
facebook instagram whatsapp and
messenger are coming back online now
founder mark zuckerberg said sorry for
the disruption today i know how much you
rely on our services to stay connected
with the people you care about
the outage came just hours after a
former facebook employee accused the
company of putting profits before safety
with a damning series of accusations
facebook has realized that
if they change the algorithm to be safer
people will spend less time on the site
they'll click on less ads they'll make
less money facebook has said that to
suggest it encourages bad content and
does nothing is not true and there is no
suggestion that there's any link between
the outage and the accusations
the whistleblower francis hogan will
testify here before congress later
governments globally have been concerned
for some time about the company's reach
its influence and its safeguards
in our view this is just the latest in a
series of revelations about social media
platforms that make clear that
self-regulation is not working
facebook founder mark zuckerberg has
repeatedly defended his company in
congress and beyond this latest
challenge puts the spotlight again on
profound questions for facebook it shows
too just how drawn so many of us are to
the products of one private
self-regulated company mark stone sky
news in washington
uh well our u.s correspondent greg milam
joins us now from facebook hq in menlo
park in california at morning greg well
that's an evening that facebook would
wish never to see repeated
yeah and usually these outages in the
tech world last about an hour and it's
of the scale and scope of this one that
has got so much attention as mark said
there
five hours of it even when it started to
get back to normal it was very very slow
and sporadic before people had
everything up and running they've
apologized they've said thanks to their
users because they realize what was at
stake for many of those users it's not
just about posting pictures and status
updates for hundreds of thousands of
people all around the world this was
about their ability to do business they
run their businesses through facebook
whatsapp has 2 milli 2 billion users for
many of those people it is their only
form of communication and they felt very
vulnerable without that or without the
ability to do business it shows how much
facebook is now part of critical
infrastructure in the us and around the
world even facebook's own engineers
trying to get to the root of this
problem found that the bits of it that
were down meant they couldn't um
couldn't get to the cause of that
problem it even slowed down the recovery
so it shows you how significant it is
they've said the cause wasn't malicious
they found out that it was this what
they call networking instruction uh
problem that they've put right but big
questions and a lot of those businesses
wondering whether it's good to rely on
facebook when something like today
happens
greg many thanks indeed
let's turn our attention now to the
conservative party conference joining us
from manchester uh once again on the
programme the minister for crime and
policing kit malthouse good to see you
this morning minister and don't worry i
will not be quizzing you on your
whatsapp group this morning uh instead i
do want to talk about a bit of video
that emerged yesterday actually filmed
not too far away from from my neck of
the woods here in london which showed a
paramedic pulling one of the members of
insulate britain from the middle of the
road
something needs to be done about this
now doesn't it
yeah it does i mean this is really
distressing stuff that's emerging now
and
while we obviously
all value the right to protest there is
a difference between causing disruption
and causing damage
we believe that these protesters and
some of the others that we've seen in
the last uh couple of years have crossed
the line
between exercising their right but also
their responsibility towards the rest of
us and something needs to be done and so
today we're going to be announcing a
raft of new measures alongside those
already in the police crime courts and
sentencing bill that's going through the
house of lords at the moment that we
think will help deal with this problem
specifically recognizing that disruption
of infrastructure and disruption of the
strategic road network is of a different
scale of damage if you like to the rest
of us uh than you would otherwise find
with a normal protest so you'll be
hearing more about that later today why
did the injunction that the the
government sought at the high court why
was that not sufficient to bring an end
to these protests
well it's a good question
now not least because most people will
respond to an injunction because
obviously injunction is effectively a
kind of civil warning that if you fail
to obey the objection there will be
consequences now to get to that
consequences step because it's a civil
procedure we have to apply to the high
court the injunction has to be served a
committal hearing has to be scheduled
and those people have to have the chance
to appear to defend themselves and that
all takes time in the meantime while the
police can arrest these
protesters and charge them for
obstructing the highway the charge at
the moment isn't severe enough that they
can be detained in custody pending an
appearance in court that means that
these people in particular are then free
to go and repeat offend as we've seen
now eventually given that they are as
far as i can see in breach of that
injunction they will appear in front of
a judge and face the wrath of that judge
but in the meantime we need to think
about this particular legal loophole if
you like to give the police more power
to deal with this very severe disruption
and you and i have both heard the really
distressing stories about people
struggling to get to hospital for god's
sake i mean the leader saying i see in
the media today uh that he would stand
in the way of somebody who was dying in
an ambulance in order to make his point
well we just don't think that's
acceptable it's crossing the line and as
i say we'll be we'll be taking strong
measures to deal with it and the the
other big topic that will be touched on
by the home secretary later on today is
violence against women and i hope you
don't mind that we devote the rest of
our time together to dealing with this
particular topic she's expected to say
that she's redoubling her efforts to
ensure women and girls feel safer do you
accept the fact that in this country we
have a problem with violence against
women
oh yes i think we all accept that and
that's why earlier this summer we
published a violence against women or
girls strategy why we commissioned the
inspector for constabulary to look at
the policing of violence against women
and and girls we had a report on that
earlier this summer obviously over the
last couple of years i've been policing
minister and we've done a lot of work in
this area particularly concentrating for
example on domestic murder and domestic
violence and i've been leading the work
in the government on the regrettably you
know disgracefully low conviction rates
that we have around rape and sexual
assault so there's been a lot of work
that's been ongoing but look we still
have a a problem um in this country
that's been encapsulated in the response
to some of the horrible murders not
least sarah everard and sabine nasa that
we've seen over the last couple of weeks
to which we as a government have to
respond
and the fact that there are too many
women and girls out there who just feel
unsafe in the public realm does demand
that we constantly increase and
reinforce our efforts to make sure that
they and everybody else feels safe sure
but but this has let's let's be fair
about it this has happened on your watch
the conservatives have been in person
since since 2010. so rather than judging
you on the promises that you're making
right now shouldn't we be judging you on
that on that record that you have just
mentioned rape convictions at a low they
have dropped so significantly over the
past five years that when the rape
review came out in june of this year the
victims commissioner vera baird said
this what we are witnessing is the
decriminalization of rape why should
anyone trust the conservatives to be
able to sort this out
well look we have obviously apologized
uh profoundly for that fall the reasons
behind it are complicated
and to do with issues of disclosure in
court and a loss of confidence if you
like between the police and the cps
about dealing with those cases what i
well what i think people want to see is
that we are very focused on this issue
and we've pledged to try and drive those
numbers up and as i say i'm leading that
task force we've been doing that for the
last a few months to try and restore
that institutional confidence if you
like and people coming forward now i
would say that during that same period
the confidence of people to come forward
and report that crime has increased very
significantly so we've seen a big rise
in reporting um uh over the last four or
five years we have to respond to that
operationally and make sure that more of
those cases to get into court but it's
worth bearing
but again as you say in the rape review
ministers collectively said they were
deeply ashamed understandable given the
fact since 2016-17 the volume of cases
prosecuted has dropped by 60
the amount of convictions that we're
securing has further dropped women do
not feel safe on the streets honestly
right now for the conservatives to
describe themselves as the party of
party of law and order would be somewhat
hubristic wouldn't it
i don't think so i mean i think that's
unfair right i mean we are obviously
trying to propose a strong package of
messages which will give people a sense
of security in the public realm women
and girls obviously primary amongst
those groups the prime minister came
into office whatever two years ago
and having been a crime-fighting mayor
in london with a proud history i have to
say of dealing with violence against
women and girls we published that city
all the first ever strategy to deal with
this issue uh in the country and in a
major capital city around the
world this has been a thread of activity
for him and i have to say that's great
to actually do something about it yep it
was in terms of an opposition day but
you voted against the full rollout of
section 28 which would allow for the
cross-examination of vulnerable
witnesses to be pre-recorded rather than
take place in court you also voted
against making street harassment a
specific crime you had an opportunity to
do something about it admittedly
presented by the labour party but rather
than hold your nose and do it you voted
against it
no that i mean again i think you're
mischaracterizing the nature of those
debates in the in the house and by the
way what happens in the house of commons
very often has little to do with what
actually happens out there on the street
so for example on your section 28 point
we have rolled out section 28 for
vulnerable victims to every single crown
court in the land and we are at the
moment carefully rolling it out in these
cases to a specific number of crown
courts to make sure that it works and it
embeds because of course section 28
while it is obviously of use for victims
who feel vulnerable to give their
testimony early it does present
cross-examination problems later down
the line now we need to make sure that
the interests of justice that we roll
that out in a proportionate and a fair
way rather than just a blanket easy
solution and it's worth remembering neil
that these are very very complicated and
difficult crimes some of the most
difficult to investigate and prosecute
and while it's it's easy for the labour
party to to make these big bold claims
you know we need to be focused on
results and that no one is denying that
these crimes are difficult to prosecute
minister no one is denying that but the
reason this is so difficult to prosecute
is because of the cuts that you have
made to the system since 2010 the cps
has faced a 25 budget cut 30 reduction
in staff police forces in england and
wales have lost 22 000 officers between
march 2010 and march 2018. you're
building them back up again but fair
enough they're still historically low
the ministry of justice has seen its
budget cut by 25
up until 2019 2020. those are the
actions that you have taken and we are
seeing the outcomes
no i don't think that's fair and i
wouldn't connect the two uh i mean
obviously for the first robert buckland
whatever
the previous justice secretary
like all parts of the public service big
choices were made in the last decade
because of the position that we all
faced economically and that that cuts
were a factor i think is self-evidently
the case robert buckland said that
well i'm afraid i disagree with him and
i can point you to an example right when
when the prime minister and i were at
city hall
when we arrived in 2008 uh knife crime
was rising very significantly at the
time police officer numbers in london
were an all-time high and gordon brown
was spending money like water on all the
things that you've talked about now we
managed to get those numbers down
against the background of of cuts that
we were making to the metropolitan
police budget because we had to the
country was facing a financial crisis
and over the first five years of that
term or so crime fell now obviously
things have to move and crime is agile
and times change and so we have to be as
well and what we're trying to do is
design a package of criminal justice
policies and capacity and capability
that will deal with the challenges we
face now and they are very different to
the challenges that were faced 10 years
ago some of those like the issue we've
talked about about rape come about
because of developments in the criminal
justice system and development in
society others of them like the the
growth in online fraud are because of
developments in technology and what i
think the british public want to see is
the government which is committed and
agile in that response and that is what
i think you'll see today on the on the
conference floor
no one least of all me will criticize
this government if they manage to
improve the rape conviction rate but it
does rather feel that it has taken the
rape and murder of a young woman by a
serving police officer to give you all a
kick up the backside to try and do
something about this
well again while this is obviously a
dreadful dreadful event and it has
encapsulated a feeling in the country i
think that's unfair too the rape review
looking at this issue of the fallen rape
convictions was initiated two years ago
um to do a root and branch review of
what was going wrong in the system we're
seeing the fruits of that work now now
the violence of women against girls
strategy was initiated i think 18 months
ago published in july this year again
engaging with the sector to work out
what we need to do so there have been
lots and lots of strands of work around
this but look neil you know the fight
against crime is never ending and i
think what the british people want to
know is that we are dedicated that we
are bothered that we are being
industrious and throwing everything we
can at it and as i say we are designing
a system which can deal with the
challenges of today
rather than argue about the challenges
of a decade ago and i think and hope
that people will start to feel that in
the years to come
minister thanks for joining us
thank you
still to come on the program at five
class dates i'll be discussing public
trust in the police force with graham
wetton a former police officer and of
course the policing commentator
the twenty past eight i'll be speaking
to the chief executive of a logistics
firm about the ongoing supply crisis and
the government's plans to recruit more
hgv drivers
[Music]
and it's half past eight i'll be
speaking to stanley johnson about his
passion to tackle climate change ahead
of the cop 26 summit
uh now china has flown a record number
of fighter planes towards taiwan amidst
growing fears of further escalation
causing condemnation from the white
house uh let's bring in our asia
correspondent tom cheshire joining us
from beijing morning tom just how
concerned should we be about this
it's pretty remarkable neil that just
the number involved we see a lot of
these incursions into taiwan's air
defense zone but when it was 56
yesterday they made the flight
it's just a huge number and something we
weren't necessarily expecting um there
is a reason for this a background for
this it's china's national day it's been
a holiday here a holiday all week and to
celebrate that they often have some sort
of military display it's just taking
place near taiwan this time but i think
also the context in the region is really
really important you have of course the
orca security alliance the new alliance
between australia uk and us and those
nuclear submarines announced quite
recently
you had a royal navy ship go down the
taiwan strait and also the queen
elizabeth aircraft carrier is doing
joint exercises with other navies
including japan in the region you've
also got japan talking publicly about
its deepening ties with taiwan i think
this is what china can do to say it's
not going to be boxed in by these moves
it's still going to fly these flights
and the other very important thing the
u.s
state department they put out a
statement saying that china should cease
its operations after a record-breaking
day uh immediately after that there's
even another record-breaking date so
china's showing it is not going to back
down here but although there is this
difficult uh
increase in quantity the quality is the
same they've been making these
incursions for a time what would be more
dangerous more foreboding is if it
changes from the air defense
identification zone which actually
extends over mainland china and it
doesn't not breaking international law
to flights over taiwan itself we're not
there yet but it's certainly a dangerous
moment here and in the region
tom many thanks
love this the latest james bond film has
smashed box office records generating 25
million pounds in three days in the uk
and ireland
james
fate draws us back together what's gonna
be there there it is
yeah no time to die had the highest
opening weekend of any film in the near
60-year history of the bond franchise
topping its predecessor scaffold and
spectre it's taken 89 million quid
internationally and looks set to break
even more records and i'm going to see
it later on today let's take a quick
look at some of the other stories making
the news this morning and two doses of
the pfazer coronavirus jab are 90
effective in preventing people going to
hospital with covid19 including the
delta variant for at least six months
researchers found that vaccine
effectiveness against all variants waned
during the six-month study period they
say their research underscores the
importance of increasing vaccination
rates around the world
let's take a look at the latest domestic
covered data and there have been a
further 35 07 new cases reported in the
latest 24 hours a further 33 people have
died after contracting covet taking the
total number of people who died within
28 days of a test to 136
9886
meanwhile 24
123 first doses of a covered vaccine
were given 21
532 received their second
nearly 45 million people have now had
two doses
around 22 percent of filling stations in
london and the southeast still do not
have fuel according to the petrol
retailers association
around 200 military personnel half of
them drivers are being deployed to the
roads for the first time to help deliver
petrol to four courts the chancellor
says the government will do all it can
to mitigate global supply issues but did
not rule out christmas being affected
an emergency operation is underway to
contain a spillage of over a hundred
thousand gallons of crude oil off the
coast of california
it's turned one of the into the state's
most popular beaches jet black littered
with dead dead birds and fish
authorities say the leak is no longer
active they're investigating whether it
was caused by a ship's anchor hitting
the pipeline
but environmental activists say that
this isn't the first time such a
disaster has occurred
and so long as the united states depends
on oil it won't be the last
let's have a quick look at the impact of
climate change on the planet the top
line there uh how our nation's power is
being generated just less than 30 coming
from fossil fuels this morning then you
have the rise in global temperature
since records began then the estimated
time uh until we have a rise of one and
a half degrees celsius and then that
huge figure at the bottom there the
total co2 emissions in millions of tons
just a reminder that you can get all the
latest on the sky news daily climate
show airing every weekday evening at
half past six
more earthquakes have rattled the
spanish island of la palma as the lava
flow from the erupting volcano surged
when part of the crater collapsed
officials said they didn't expect to
evacuate any more people from the area
because the molten rock was following
the same route to the sea as earlier
floats more than a thousand properties
mostly homes have been partially or
completely destroyed by the lava
the first treatment for sickle cell
disease in over 20 years will be rolled
out to thousands of patients in england
our reporter aisha hit joins us from the
newsroom to tell us more aisha
significant breakthrough this
it absolutely is it's been described as
a life-changing drug treatment we know
that there are around 15 000 people in
the uk who suffer from sickle cell
disease and if we look at what sickle
cell is it's a hereditary disorder it
predominantly affects those of a african
and caribbean descent leaving people in
severe pain in incidents which are
called a sickle cell crisis which has to
then be treated with morphine in order
to avoid organ failure now this new
medication krizan li zumab it prevents
the restriction of blood and oxygen that
can lead to a crisis and the nhs says it
can help
it potentially will help as many as 5
000 people over the next three years
they're hoping it will also lead to a
reduction in the a and e visits people
suffering from sickle cell will have to
make so real hopes here that it will
help improve quality of life
aisha thanks very much indeed
now how safe are our children when they
play nearly half of toys tested in a
recent study that were bought from
online third-party sellers could have
choked burnt
poisoned or electrocuted a child the
figures from the british toy and hobby
association have led the group to call
for urgent changes to the law so that
children can play without risk of injury
or even death as jemima walker reports
purple cargo
two-year-old rebecca is all smiles now
playing with her favorite toys
but earlier this year a toy almost cost
her her life
she mistook some magnets for sweets and
swallowed them they were so strong they
ruptured her intestines
the doctor's faces just dropped and
within 15 minutes of me saying magnets
we were in an ambulance blue light to
raw london hospital so i took her down
to surgery and they prepped me and i
took her in
and she was docile but she was like no
mommy no no no so i physically had to
hold her down
or they put her to sleep sam bought the
magnets on ebay via a third party
now a survey of randomly selected toys
has found potentially lethal items
flooding online marketplaces
88 of the items examined by the british
toy and hobby association were illegal
under uk safety law
48 were unsafe and could cause choking
strangulation or chemical poisoning
there's currently no legal requirement
for online marketplaces to check the
safety of products like these
this one is
a crocodile which has been on sale for
the whole three years of our project
we buy it in every every time we we do a
test of the marketplaces it has an open
zip
with access to the stuffing and the zip
actually pulls off and becomes a small
part which can be a choking hazard for
young children which is what it's aimed
at if you're buying generic toys from
the third-party sellers
that you really don't know and you can't
see their address and their names
they've got no eu or uk address that's
the highest risk area
ebay says it works closely with
standards authorities and has filters
which block millions of unsafe listings
but trade bodies and consumer groups
want the law toughened up
there is no one who is checking that
third-party retailers are actually
conducting the safety checks and we
believe that online marketplaces now
must have that legal responsibility
should we make some cookies
with christmas on the horizon many
parents will be turning online to do
their shopping
sam wants them to be vigilant
so a dream present doesn't turn into a
nightmare jeremiah walker sky news
well it really is the stuff of science
fiction captain james t kirk is heading
back into space
leave me aboard energize energize
[Music]
never anything better than that well
next week the 90 year old star trek
actor william shatner will become the
oldest ever person to blast into space
for real a trip he is describing as a
miracle one hopes
it's slightly less problematic than
previous trips anyway coming up soon
we'll be speaking to the president of
the cbi lord bilimuria to get his view
on the chancellor's speech yesterday at
the tory party conference
[Music]
has just reopened our international
borders as of uh friday
and over the weekend we are being
inundated with british tourists who are
flying in for much needed uh holiday
rest and relaxation
so mauritius has had one of the
strongest uh responses to the kobe
pandemic in fact it went in through a
very very hard 18-month
uh international board of restrictions
which partially reopened uh back in july
and fully reopened here on friday the
1st of october and the russian
government policy
was to vaccinate first and reopen second
so the country is now at a spectacular
89
vaccination rate of adults it's
also vaccinating
children and teenagers and is also now
going into the booster uh
vaccinations so
the response to covid is world-class
when we reached um
those levels of vaccination rates we
decided it was safe to open the borders
and as a result fully vaccinated uh
visitors from around the world are now
able to arrive in mauritius with a piece
of pre-departure pcr test and then two
anti-gen tests here on arrival and after
day five
but now the borders will be opening
hotels are fully uh reopening people are
coming back to their jobs and indeed uh
just the overwhelming joy of people uh
who work in the travel and tourism
sector here in mauritius of welcoming
the world back uh to the island uh has
been a fantastic thing to be part of
[Music]
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond is necessary to replenish these
groundwater resources
[Music]
welcome back the crime and policing
minister at kit malt house has told us
this morning that protesters from the
insulate britain group have crossed a
line by blocking roads let's head
north to manchester our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen is at the
conservative party conference uh what
did we hear from kitten as we know that
there's going to be action on this but
frankly he he expressed a level of
disquiet indeed anger i perhaps detected
there that some might find
surprising
hi neil yes it's very much law and order
day at the tory party conference with
lots of tough new measures being
announced but the key one is that the
home secretary priti patel who's
speaking later this morning
wants to take action against those
insulate britain protesters who have
been preventing people from driving
along the m25 and the m1 motorway in
recent weeks and the measures that have
already been announced these injunctions
to try and get the courts to stop them
haven't so far worked now kit malthouse
the policing minister said the next step
is these kind of asbo style orders
called criminal disruption prevention
orders and the idea is that individual
protesters who are judged to be
disrupting critical infrastructure can
be handed one of these orders they'll
have to go to court and get it from a
judge which will prevent them attending
and from traveling around the country to
attend these protests but of course it
may take weeks to get through parliament
in order to be activated
tamara thanks very much indeed
well the conservative party conference
has been rocked by allegations of an
assault against one of its women's
speakers
and happened as violence against women
was discussed both on the platform and
in fringe events the man alleged to have
been involved was told to leave the
conference
well last night the sky news program the
great debate asked the question are
women safe on our streets reflecting the
rising concern in the country here's our
political correspondent kate mccann
for weeks violence against women and
girls and how police and society react
to it has been on many of our minds it's
dominated conversation at conservative
party conference too
i spoke at a meeting yesterday and
someone asked about the sarah reverage
case and my thoughts and i sort of said
i sort of tried to gaze the reaction of
the women in the room and said can
anyone here raise your hand if you've
ever felt unsafe walking home in the
evening and every single woman in that
room lays their hand you know for
example a chap followed me home while i
was walking home one night about a month
ago there was nothing particularly
sinister in it but still i felt
incredibly unsafe and vulnerable for the
next week or so i was looking over my
shoulder
an allegation of assault at this very
event has now prompted difficult
questions
last night i was violently assaulted in
in the conference zone by by a man in
the in the midlands bar so i do want to
just take the opportunity to say women
um
are often unsafe in places where other
people feel safe and it's really
important that we start to take that
much more seriously as a society and and
starting with the police
this is the bar where the alleged
incident took place a conference
attendee has since had his pass
suspended it's well lit full of people
and inside a secure zone yet one young
woman was made to feel unsafe here
others we've spoken to felt the same way
their message is clear that government
spending to make streets safer can't
solve this problem when women are being
abused in places like this it takes much
deeper fundamental change
but that change is hard to achieve last
night sky's great debate program asked
whether women are safe on our streets
former home secretary amber rudd called
for a rethink
hopefully this is a moment when we look
at the culture and try to change that
because it's completely wrong and i
think it feels to me like people are
going to push for cultural change and
that could happen if the men as well
reject the situation that we're in now
it mustn't just be the women saying so
for survivors the impact is all too
clear
as far as i'm aware this man still lives
local i live in fear i live in fear all
the time and it's affected me as a
mother it's affected me with my job and
what i wear i'm not safe at home i'm not
safe out of the home
and
where is my safe place who's going to
protect me
today priti patel will stand on stage
just a stone's throw from where that
alleged incident took place she will
promise to redouble her efforts to
tackle violence against women but
there's unlikely to be any new policy in
her speech and women want more than
words they want action
kate mccann sky news in manchester
well the chancellor rishi sunak spoke at
the conservative conference yesterday
saying he would only consider cutting
taxes once public finances are on a
sustainable footing following the
coronavirus crisis he also announced the
push towards science and technology
aiming to make the uk a global leader in
ai technology joining us now the
president of the cbi lords bellamoria
lord belimore early start for you so we
appreciate you joining us what did you
make of the chancellor's speech
yesterday
the chancellor's speech was very good
in in terms of obviously putting
business up front right and center
being fiscally prudent
uh however
it's investment investment investment he
spoke about the super deduction which
was a fantastic initiative by this
government what we're asking for is for
the government to focus on really
promoting investment in business
domestic investment inward investments
were broad that's to generate the growth
to generate the jobs that will pay the
taxes that will pay down
the debt and and the more of that we can
see the better and this is the time for
business and government to work closely
together more than ever it was just in
may that we were told by the chief
economist of the imf that britain was in
a very strong position with 400 billion
pounds of spend to save businesses in
the economy through the pandemic and a
fantastic vaccination program that we
should have a bounce back a v-shaped
recovery but what's happened in the
months since then is we've had the
energy crisis we've had the fuel crisis
we've had labor shortages not just lorry
drivers financial services hospitality
butchers welders across the whole
economy and we've got a
recovery that is actually very fragile
so we at the cbi saying to government
now's the time
set up a cobra style task force of
government and business working side by
side so we can tackle these issues these
crises together in the run-up to
christmas this is going to be a crucial
time to make sure the recovery is robust
and resilient
given the fragile nature of the economy
though i do wonder whether you the
members of the the cbi are as sanguine
as the prime minister about focusing you
know in a large part or on increasing
wages on driving wages up is that being
the barometer of success
there's no question that we would all
like a higher wage economy but we also
would like a higher productive economy
because higher wages without higher
productivity leads to inflation and if
you have inflation without growth if you
have stagg stagflation that is a really
dangerous position to be in and
inflation is already climbing and
predicted to climb to four four and a
half percent uh and predicted to stay as
such until the sum of next year now we
need inflation around two percent if we
have persistent inflation that is
something that would be of concern to
the government to the business community
because then it could lead to interest
rates going up interest rates go up at
such a low level the lowest rate since
the bank of england was founded in 1692
if we have the interest rates going up
that affects government borrowing it
affects mortgages affects consumers it
affects business so we've got to try and
control that inflation uh and of course
we would not want a high paid higher
wage economy everyone would want that
you mentioned on person that the
problems that many companies
are having in terms of recruitment at
the moment yet lots and lots of people
on payroll but there are a huge number
of job vacancies i mean absent some
return
some visa scheme or whatever can we get
the people to fill the jobs that are
already there without reaching out to
about the continent basically
we have a situation where we've had the
furlough scheme that has protected uh
employment unemployment now people had
predicted by this stage we would go up
to 10
before the pandemic unemployment was one
of its lowest levels ever three and a
half percent today it's four and a half
percent and hats off to the government
for enabling that to happen
predominantly through the fellow scheme
and all the other measures that we've
had that business is grateful for we've
got about a million people now who come
off furlough will they be able to go
into the vacancies that are desperately
needed there's some firms that have
thousands of vacancies per company
what we're saying is with the points
based immigration system the
understanding always was we don't want
we no longer have open immigration but
can we have access to labor where we
need it from around the world when the
economy desperately needs it and various
suggestions have been put forward we
need to think creatively about this
whether it's having the migration
advisory committee an independent body
like the monetary policy committee sets
interest rates every month if we have an
independent body that says this is a
labor requirement you need a few
thousand people in this sector or that
sector independently advise the
government on a temporary basis no one
is saying bring people in permanently on
a temporary basis in the way that the
government has just done for lorry
drivers for workers in the poultry
sector
it was three months now they've extended
beyond three months it's got to be for a
reasonable period of time to attract the
people in
uh lord bill murray buzzwords and
phrases are very very popular in
business these days and i'm sure just
like me you are a blue sky thinker but
are you any closer to understanding what
leveling up and building back better
actually mean
well i i don't like the term building
back better i prefer the term building
forward better we've got to build
forward together and leveling up of
course prosperity around the regions is
crucial london is the greatest of the
world's great cities and long may london
prosper it's never going to be london or
the rest of the uk the better london
does the better it is for the whole of
the country but we also need to make
sure we have prosperity around the
country and that's why we at the cbi
promoting the concept of clusters like
cambridge where you have the university
tech around it and now biosciences
oxford astrozenica vaccine astrozenicus
headquartered in cambridge the more we
promote clusters the more we invest
throughout the united kingdom the more
prosperous the more competitive the more
productive and we've got so much to go
for i'm very optimistic if we tackle
this fragile recovery with government
and business closely working together
we're going to be absolutely in a great
place
always good to have a bit of optimism at
this time on a tuesday morning lord
belimoria good to see you this morning
thanks being with us
now
six years since our last album seems the
internet is abuzz with rumors of the
return of a british music legend
yep
[Music]
you might heard that a couple of times
before it looks like adele is ready to
say hello all over again
rumor has it that's a song title i
believe uh that the singer is ready to
release her next album six years after
the critically acclaimed 25. so over the
weekend mysterious billboards with the
number 30 starting to appear all across
the world edinburgh new york seoul adele
has now changed her social media profile
pictures to the color of the background
of those billboards and has issued her
one and only tweet of the last few
months saying simply
hiya babes i'm not going to do the
accent
more after the break including some
stark warnings from the health
foundation that public health funding is
continuing to fall i'll be speaking to
them next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over to phillip
no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who've made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
christchurch has been changed forever by
what happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
did you know that air pollution isn't
just bad for the environment it's bad
for our health too
[Music]
it'll be windy with persistent rain for
central parts and showers elsewhere
plong drain will become largely confined
to northern england during the morning
with blustery showers developing widely
to the south
scotland ireland and northern ireland
will be mostly fine just a few showers
there east anglia will turn wet later
and gales will develop on north sea
coasts the unsettled windy conditions
mean the atmosphere will be well mixed
so the air pollution index where one
means low pollution and 10 means very
high will be low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now a number of leading health bodies
are warning this morning that there is
one massive gap in boris johnson's
leveling up program public health
funding
analysis from the health foundation has
found that the public health grant has
been cut by almost a quarter in real
terms since 2015
and that cut has been felt
disproportionately by more deprived
areas of the country uh here to tell us
a little bit more about their research
at joe bibby director of health at the
health foundation joe lovely to see you
this morning and just take us through in
a little bit more depth if you can
exactly what this research has revealed
the public health grant has experienced
some pretty significant cuts
yeah that's right so as you say today
the health foundation along with 50
other leading charities is calling on
the government to put an extra 1.4
billion pounds into our public health
system
and public health
it's there to help us stay healthy
throughout our lives so it's the work of
health visitors with families and babies
services to help people quit smoking and
overcome addiction or as we've seen in
the last year the expert advice and
action needed to manage infectious
diseases such as covet but despite this
vital role that public health plays in
keeping people healthy their funding has
been cut by nearly a quarter over the
past six years and at the same time the
need for their services has grown so
smoking remains the biggest killer we
need to support more people to quit
smoking obesity is continuing to rise
and during the pandemic we've seen
increases in harm from alcohol and as
you say what's concerning is these cuts
in public health spending have been
deepest in some of the areas of greatest
need such as blackpool where people face
shorter lives in poorer health than many
other parts of the country so while it's
right the government is committing extra
funds for the nhs without the 1.4
billion pounds needed for public health
to
help people stay healthy this would just
be a short-term fix and it won't stem
the tide of ill health joe just just in
terms of your point that the cat's
falling most heavily on those living in
in the most deprived parts of the
country i mean is that in part because
you know the most deprived parts of the
country
will tend to be accessing the health
services
whatever form they may take maybe
they'll be accessing them rather more
frequently
um no so i think what's worth
understanding is the um
there's a the funding for the nhs and
that's the kind of services most people
will think about in terms of their gps
and hospitals and there's a separate
funding stream for public health and
that funding stream goes through local
government
and when the money was transferred over
into local government
around about 10 years ago
just there were different sizes of
budgets um transferred over in the first
place so it wasn't very equally
distributed in the first place and then
because we've seen
all local government spending cut quite
severely over the past
eight to ten years you know places that
have had to make judgments about do i
put money into social care do i put it
into housing do i put it into public
health they've had to make very
difficult decisions and i guess this is
why we've seen in some places the size
of the grant has just become
smaller and smaller over the years
because these are the places they've got
many multiple problems that they're
trying to manage not just the healthcare
system but wider um problems that they
need to work on if they're going to
support people to have good lives
joe just in terms of doing the kind of
the more eye-catching parts of your
research we've been talking about the
the deep health inequalities you
mentioned blackpool girls born there are
expected to live for 12 and a half years
fewer than those who are in good health
in the richest part of the country
i'm just wondering what can be done
about that level of disparity is there
an amount of money that can be spent to
sort it out
well you're right to highlight this and
i think generally um we're probably not
aware of the extent of the inequalities
that exist in people's health across the
country
but
what we're saying at the health
foundation is this is all about keeping
people healthy in the first place
so we know the most important things for
people's health is around
good work good incomes um it's about the
houses they live in and you know yes
it's about the food systems the kind of
food they're able to access and so on
um
so government if it's talking about
leveling up um it also needs to level up
health and it needs to think about how
it's um closing some of these gaps in
terms of good quality work um and
support to people around the country and
the public health grant is one of the
most efficient areas of spending of
government that the government can do we
know that spending for instance on
alcohol services can make a huge
difference and prevent
a lot of avoidable hospital admissions
very costly hospital conditions and we
know it can also
prevent people getting
illnesses and prevent early death so
there's no one single thing that can be
done to close that gap in healthy life
expectancy but the public health grant
is probably one of the most cost
effective areas of spending for
government in this respect
well let us see if the government
listens to you on this occasion uh joel
baby from the health foundation good to
see you this morning thanks for being
with us thank you thank you
let's check in and see how the weather
is looking well followers of my social
media will know that it was tipping down
outside the studio this morning england
and wales can expect pretty heavy rain
largely drying out later though but more
rain is heading to northern and western
parts to end the week it is cold in the
north with apache frost and some fog
fairly mild wet and windy for much of
england and wales
northern england will remain mostly
overcast and wet through the morning
although cumbria should brighten up
while wales and southern england will
see a scattering of blustery sharks
let's just bring you some live pictures
from la palma uh the volcano continuing
to erupt there as earthquakes rattle the
island
some occasions like this you can really
hear the power of the mantle just
beneath at the surface of the earth at
more than a thousand properties mostly
homes though have been partially or
completely destroyed by the lava no end
in sight for the poor residents of la
palma